we have a hairy looking expression here
and your goal is to try to simplify it
as much as you can and i'll give you a
little bit of time to do it
let's just think about it step by step
and it might help if we were to actually
reorder the terms in this expression so
let me put all the x terms first so i
have 5 x that's that term minus 2x
minus 2x
then i have plus 7y
plus 7y
plus 3y
plus 3y then i have plus 8z
plus
8z and then i have minus z
minus z and then the last term that i
haven't included yet is that plus five
this plus five right over here now let's
just think it through if i have five of
five x's and i were to take away two x's
how many x's am i going to be left with
well i'm going to be left with three x's
that's true of anything there's not some
fancy algebraic magic going on here five
of anything minus two of that same thing
you're going to be left with three of
that thing in the in this case that
thing are x's so this is going to
simplify
this right over here is going to
simplify to 3x now in a lot of algebra
classes you will hear people say oh well
you know the coefficient on 5x is 5 and
the coefficient on this subtracting the
2x the coefficient here is negative 2
and we had to add the coefficients let
me write that word down
coe
coefficient
these right over here are the
coefficients they're the number that
you're multiplying the variable by so
you're the 5 or the negative 2 in this
case and so we you could just say oh i
had to just add the coefficients and
that's okay and there's nothing wrong
with that but i really want to emphasize
that there's a very common sense
intuition here if you have five of
something you take away two of that
something you are left with three of
that something and you also it's you
have to be very careful you have to make
sure that you're adding and subtracting
the same things here we're dealing with
x's so we can take five x's and take
away two x's we can't think about
merging the x's and the y's at least not
in any simple way right now so because
that frankly wouldn't make any intuitive
sense
now let's think about the y's if i have
seven of something and i were to add 3
more of that something well then i'm
going to have 10 of that something so
that's going so this part right over
here is going to simplify to
10
y once again you could say the
coefficient on 7 y is 7 the coefficient
on 3y is 3 we added the coefficients 7
plus 3 to get 10y but i really want to
emphasize the intuition here it's much
more if you got 7 of something you had
another 3 that's something you got 10 of
that something
now let's look at the z's if i've got
eight of something and i take away one
of them i'm going to have seven of that
something so that is 7z and you might
say wait what was the coefficient right
here on this negative z i don't see any
number out front of the z well
implicitly i could have put a one here
and it's exactly the same thing
subtracting a z is the exact same thing
as subtracting one z the word one z
strikes a part of my brain because i
have very young children but that's a
different type of one z
and then you could see oh yeah you
definitely did add the two coefficients
the eight and the negative one but once
again common sense tells you if you have
eight of something and you take away one
of them you have seven of that something
and then finally and then finally you
have a
you have a plus 5. so we're done this
simplified to 3x
plus 10y
plus 7z
plus
5.